it is day two of cop 27 let's take you
live now to the climate Summit in Egypt
the prime minister of Pakistan is
speaking about Sharif addressing uh the
dignitaries there this address comes
just months after more than a thousand
people were killed in his country
millions of others forced from their
homes by devastating floods Pakistan's
government has blamed climate change
damage and loss
has exceeded 30 billion dollars
and this all happened despite our very
low
carbon footprints
and yet
we became a victim of
something
with which we had nothing to do
and of course
it was a man-made disaster
Mr President the priorities of Pakistan
have never been
clearer first
the global goal on adaptation needs to
be prioritized both in terms of
financing and timelines
we are yet to see the promised
half and half balance in adaptation and
mitigation Finance
the current financing Gap
is too high to sustain any real recovery
needs of those on the front lines of
climate catastrophe
second
laws in damage needs to be part of the
core agenda of cop27 to meet the
pressing humanitarian needs of those
that are trapped in a crisis of public
financing
fueled by debt and yet have to fund
climate disasters on their own
this is simply unjust and unfair
to say the least
third Mr President climate Finance must
be clearly defined
as new
additional and sustained Resources with
a transparent mechanism that meets the
needs of developing and vulnerable
countries with the speed and scale that
is required
there should now be total clarity
on what actually counts as climate
transfer and what counts as development
fines
for instance as they often overlap
excellencies we have been take talking
for years but have failed to even agree
on the basics
pledges made at the Copenhagen cop 15 in
2009 for mobilizing 100 billion dollars
per annum by 2020 have still not been
realized they need to be enhanced given
the increased frequency and intensity of
climate extreme events fought a global
climate Risk Index of all parties of the
UNF CCC must be created under the
auspices of the U.N system
projects from the most vulnerable
countries on this index must get
prioritized and Speedy approvals for
climate Finance
and finally mitigation ambition needs to
be revived in a clear
burden share formula
the promise of common but differentiated
responsibilities must be respected as we
raise towards a much higher trajectory
of warming
than defined in the Paris agreement
Pakistan's 2030 ambition in the indices
are already higher than many countries
but we understand our responsibilities
as we move towards a net zero plan once
we recover
accent is unless there is a
transformational shift in the flow of
capacities finance and technology that
reverses the Pyramid of climate Capital
the bargain between the North and the
South will not work
I want to share something with you
while
we were grappling
and fighting against it
torrential floods which hit Pakistan
very severely
we had to import
wheat
palm oil
and of course
very expensive
oil and gas
spending
a
roundabout
30 32 billion dollars
to finance its import
on the other
we have repurposed
redirected
are meager resources
to meet the basic needs of millions of
households affected by these
devastating floods
we had to
dish out about 316 million dollars
through a program by the name of
Income Support Program
to provide
an amount of
113 dollars per household
to about 3 million households in flood
affected areas
and now
winter is setting in
and we need to provide
shelter homes
medical treatment
and food package to these millions of
people in
different provinces of Pakistan
for which
we are spending
billions of rupees
from our own Mega resources
now imagine
ladies and gentlemen
on one hand
we have to
cater for our food security for the
Common Man
by spending billions of dollars
and on the other
we have to spend
billions of dollars
to protect
flood affected people from further
miseries
and difficulties how on Earth can one
expect from us that we will undertake
this gigantic task
on our own
of course we are thankful to
International Community
for helping us
in this difficult time
coming to a rescue
through donations and through
stuff which have been shipped through
air Freights and of course through sea
routes
but the gap
is humongous the Gap is widening by the
day
therefore
it is
the duty and responsibility
of global North to understand
our difficulties in our plight
we wouldn't want
that tomorrow God forbid some other
country
should become a victim of this
climate induced disaster and I call it
man-made disaster
it is extremely important
[Music]
that if we have to fight and rebuild
and repair our infrastructure
which is which has to be resilient
and adaptive
then of course we
can only do through
additional funding
not through additional loans and debts
because this would be a financial death
trap
I hope this conference
well not only
listen to this message
loud and clear but convey
just to all
who have the power and Financial Muscle
to change the course of history
loud and clear and that is what this
conference is meant for
ladies and gentlemen it is now or never
for us there is indeed no Planet B I
thank you for your patience God bless
you thank you your Excellency
[Applause]